sur public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous bienvenue sur
public sénat bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle saison de dialogue citoyen nous
sommes ensemble pendant une heure
citoyens citoyennes connecter depuis les
quatre coins du pays trois sénateurs
sénatrice élue de divers territoires
tous venus échanger aujourd'hui sur les
ravages que la drogue peut causer sur
des milliers d'entre nous et je dis nous
parce que nous sommes tous concernés
tous les milieux sociaux favorisés
défavorisés le trafic l'addiction la
violence vous allez entendre des
français dans le quotidien est un
calvaire comment les sortir de là
comment briser la spirale de la drogue
certains en des pistes des solutions
vous les entendrez aussi ce dialogue
vous pouvez le suivre et le commentée
sur les réseaux sociaux hashtag dialogue
citoyen sur twitter avant de vous
présenter les invités de notre première
partie je vais vous laisser découvrir en
quelques secondes le quotidien de samia
elle habite dans le quartier de
stalingrad vous en avez récemment
entendu parler avec cette affaire de
murs construits entre paris et pantin
pour empêcher les toxicomanes d'accéder
à un tunnel mur ou pas mûres cela fait
des années que cette zone est envahie
par les consommateurs de train de crack
samia a accepté de nous envoyer quelques
images regarder
[Musique]
voilà des scènes qui illustre un peu la
tension et le ras-le-bol des habitants
samia food lion vous retrouve avec nous
merci beaucoup de nous avoir envoyé ces
images vous avez 41 ans vous élever
seules vos deux enfants de 13 et 18 ans
vous habitez le quartier depuis 13 ans
je précise que vous allez bientôt
déménager notamment à cause de l'enfer
que vous y avez vécu et vous nous
raconterez votre votre quotidien céline
burgaud bienvenue à vous et merci à vous
aussi de témoigner vous avez 53 ans vous
êtes aide soignante à marseille vous
avez élevé seules six enfants et vous
vivez dans le quartier de la busserine
en coin de la ville où il ya du trafic
et des règlements de comptes dans les
années 2000 votre fils de 15 ans faisait
ce qu'on appelle le chouf pour des
dealers vous nous expliquerez ce que ça
veut dire est ce que ça impliquait pour
lui et pour vous johanna balavoine
bienvenue à vous également vous avez 35
ans vous habitez dans les pyrénées
atlantiques votre nom dit quelque chose
aux français qui nous regardent vous
êtes la fille du chanteur daniel
balavoine vous ne l'avez pas connu il
est décédé avant votre naissance vous
avez vous-même longtemps consommer de la
drogue c'était festif au début et puis
c'est devenu une addiction terrible
votre histoire on la retrouve dans cette
bd qu'on voit à l'antenne les lion
endormi on va en parler ensemble avec
vous pour échanger tout au long de cette
émission bernard jomier bienvenus vous
êtes sénateur de paris apparenté au
groupe socialiste médecin de profession
stefano rudulier bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes sénateur et l'ère
des bouches-du-rhône et sonia de la
provôté bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
sénatrice centriste du calvados médecin
également médecin du travail samia fou
délit votre quartier stalingrad on l'a
dit a refait la une il y a quelques
jours à cause du mur on va pas revenir
sur la sur la polémique mais peut-être
vous pouvez nous raconter ce qui attend
finalement les habitants de pantin le
krach a pourri votre quotidien on peut
le dire comme ça
ah oui complètement en ruines depuis la
décision de les parquer dans un jardin
pour enfin en bas de chez nous ça nous à
savoir ça vraiment pourri notre
quotidien oui pendant trois mois en
sachant qu'il n'en avait aucune présence
policière ou très peu qu'est ce que ça
voulait dire est ce que ce sont des gens
qui vous semblait ou qu'il était
dangereux qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient
dans la qu'est-ce qui vous effrayer moi
j'étais pas spécialement effrayer mais
disons que c'est un climat qui est quand
même très ambitieux gènes puisque c'est
les confrontés tous les jours des gens
malades psychotiques dans une détresse
humaine c'est une misère sous mes
fenêtres tous les jours c'est des
personnes qui peuvent avoir des contre
est donc je veux oui donc on est on
était vraiment dans pendant trois mois
confronté à sable et tous les 10 mais
qui ne pouvait plus sortir faire quoi
que ce soit ne serait-ce qu acheter une
baguette aller à la boulangerie sans
croiser y en avait que même plus que les
riverains puisque je crois qu'ils
devaient être moins 300 ou 400 sur le
pont riquet jusque sur le trottoir d'en
face en face de chez moi et pas avant
d'entrer un petit peu dans les détails
mais je sais qu'en préparant cette
émission vous nous avez décrit des
scènes qui était quand même assez assez
difficile à supporter mais qui peuvent
aider aussi nos élus et les
téléspectateurs à se rendre compte de la
situation vous disiez que vous êtes vous
aviez pu assister des rapports sexuels
dans la rue ou même à des scènes
vraiment difficile tout à fait y avait
des effectifs dans les rapports sexuels
oraux en pleine journée dans des dans
des jardins dans des halls d'immeubles
des personnes bomba qui sont
complètement déshumanisée donc qui qui
font leurs besoins devant vous c'est
c'est terrible c'est sûr on est un
quartier russe où il ya énormément
d'écoles de collèges donc dès qu'on dès
qu'on rentre du travail dès que les
enfants sortaient de l'école on était
systématiquement confrontés
à des scènes terribles on a vu une scène
de tension ces sont des images que vous
avez bien voulu nous envoyer est ce
qu'il est arrivé à des habitants d'avoir
envie de de faire la loi eux-mêmes de se
faire justice eux-mêmes de de faire ce
que peut-être les autorités ne font pas
au oui enfin c'est quand même assez rare
comme comportement quand ça arrive et on
essayait de les tempérer y avait
toujours un voisin
pour me dire de pour leur dire de se
calmer c'est pas le but de toute façon
on sait très bien que ce sont de toute
façon des victimes personnes qui ont
besoin de soins ont besoin d'être prise
en charge alors des fois oui ça pouvait
arriver qui est des confrontations des
heurts avec des dealers notamment
notamment quand ont manifesté voilà
parce que les manifestations de
riverains juste à proximité du campement
saadé plaisait aux mots doux aux dealers
puisqu'il y avait des caméras il y avait
des journalistes personne ne voulait pas
être filmée ni photographiée donc oui à
ce moment là effectivement il y avait
des ça pouvait dégénérer oui on va
continuer l'échangé et puis évidemment
vous nous faites signe si vous avez
envie de de réagir samia mais on va en
parler avec les élus sur ce plateau
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire à ses
habitants bernard jomier qui ont pu se
sentir abandonnés qui ont été laissés
dans des situations qui sont peu dire
complètement anormal alors la situation
aux points dames food et y est là elle a
affronté moi je suis j'ai été élue du
19e jusque l'année dernière ce que je
connais bien c'est moi c'est mon
arrondissement et c c'est tout à fait
anormal et c'est la résultante au fond
d'une forme d'abandon je pense que si on
veut avancer il faut se mettre d'accord
sur quelques grands principes d'abord ce
sont des personnes qui
ne faut pas laisser à la rue
deuxièmement il faut que les différents
acteurs travaillent ensemble
troisièmement ça sert à rien de les
renvoyer de territoire en territoire
mais si on ne se met pas d'accord hors
de toute polémique pour dire vous savez
le crack et les usagers de crack c'est
une des situations les plus difficiles
ce sont les personnes et plus désinsérer
les plus en rupture de tout et ne sont
pas très nombreuses en fait on les a on
les a comptés ils sont à peu près 150 à
200 pas plus qu'ils tournent d'endroit
en endroit il faut arrêter il faut
mettre en place un dispositif qui permet
de les sortir de la rue et de proposer
des solutions c'est compliqué parce
qu'ils sont tellement d insérer que
c'est déjà une victoire si on les amène
vers un programme de substitution
si on arrive à les mettre dans un
hébergement même temporaire etc donc il
faut qu'on fasse ce travail mais moi ce
que je veux dire à madame c'est que le
principe la ligne ça doit être de
réduire les risques liés à la drogue
pour les usagers qui en sont à la
prononcer le mot des victimes et pour
les riverains qui sont aussi des
victimes c'était fabuleux lle samia fou
délit nous disait en préparant cette
émission que c'était aussi un quartier
en particulier qui avaient été concernés
et que si c'était arrivé dans un autre
dans les beaux quartiers de paris ce
serait pas forcément arriver on peut se
dire qu'effectivement s'il y avait eu
150 crackers de là dans le jardin du
luxembourg juste à côté d'ici il aurait
peut-être été déplacé un peu plus
rapidement oui mais le problème n'est
pas de les déplacer rapidement c'est pas
le fond du sujet c'est le traitement de
ces personnes qui sont en totale
déshérence qui sont désocialisées
qui sont malades victimes ça a été dit
et donc il faut impérativement traiter
le sujet par des structures adaptées par
un accompagnement au quotidien
et comme le disait à juste titre mon
collègue effectivement ce ne sont pas 20
minutes trente mille personnes il s'agit
de 100 150 200 personnes et si l'état
est incapable de gérer 150 ou 200
personnes en déshérence qu'on avait
véritablement des questions à se poser
sur sur la légitimité de terre mais qui
a un rôle à jouer sonia de la provôté il
ya différents acteurs est ce que c'est
l'arrondissement est ce que c'est la
mairie est ce que c'est la région est ce
que c'est l'état
c'est un problème de santé c'est un
problème de sécurité publique c'est un
problème social
donc l'état sa part de responsabilité à
assumer dans la sphère et c'est vrai
qu'il ya une forme de révolte à la fois
d'être obligé de subir ça et aussi 2 2
face à une forme d'un curry ou j'ai pas
de l'acheter ou peut-être de déni de la
situation est clairement
glisse c'est même pas une question
institutionnelle se dire qu'il ya des
médecins il ya des personnes en charge
de la sécurité il ya des personnes en
charge l'accompagnement social c'est
pour 8m l'îlotage là existe pour tout un
tas de sujets il suffisait d'en
l'utiliser à
au niveau de l'arrondissement au niveau
de la ville de paris pour pouvoir
accompagner les choses et on va
poursuivre avec le témoignage de céline
burgaud est évidemment vous n'hésitez
pas tous à réagir même si ce n'est pas
officiellement votre tour céline burgaud
la drogue et le trafic ont aussi pourri
votre vie pendant des années c'est toi
c'est votre fils qui s'est laissé
embarquer par le trafic de drogue dans
les quartiers nord de marseille quand il
avait 15 ans il faisait le guetteur pour
les dealers et ça a mal tourné très mal
tourné ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
ce qui s'est passé en fait déjà j'ai
appris qu'il était dans les réseaux et
les week-ends donc je ne sais pas quand
est-ce qu'il va rentrer et quand j'ai su
je suis devenue folle dans le sens bien
j'ai culpabilisé en tant que mère en me
disant où est ce que j'avais foire et
quelques pas
et j'ai décidé de réagir donc j'ai
dénoncé monfils heure légale des stups
et quand j'ai expliqué la situation en
demandant de l'aide à la police la
police m'a dit démerdez vous avec le
réseau ou votre fils a le qr2
donc j'ai fait plein de de formalités
administratives j'ai fait des
déclarations juge pour avoir une enquête
avec la même eau qui est l'aide
éducative m2 ouverts et mes enfants mes
autres enfants hilton d'alger
et quand j'ai vu que ça n'aboutissait
pas j'ai décidé de déclarer la guerre
aux réseaux de me démerder tout seul
c'est à dire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
déclaré la guerre aux réseaux
ça veut dire que j'allais rien lâcher à
les affronter simplement j'ai fait
pendant trois ans j'ai lutté
et
gemalto sorte de
de la percussion
et
j'ai sorti dans le final
qu'est-ce qui vous disaient votre fille
z'imaginez que vous communiquiez un
petit peu avec lui quand même est-ce
qu'il y était de force pourquoi est il
tombé dedans est ce qu'il vous a
expliqué ça ne rentre pas on ne rentre
pas dans les réseaux de force
non pas en train de s'entraîner en
général
et mon fils est rentré de son plein gré
mais le problème c'est que au début
voulait pas sortir puisque l'argent est
comment dire la craie il a vu que
c'était dur qu'il est rentré dans un
engrenage infernal donc mais ne voulait
pas sortir parce qu'il était menacé sur
ses frères et soeurs
du coup c'est voir sur une transaction
ce qui est frappant dans votre discours
c'est qu'on a l'impression que vous avez
été complètement seul dans ce combat
vous vous confirmez vous avez été
complètement seul
j'ai été seul et j'ai été aidé au niveau
administratif et j'ai été soutenu par
une éducatrice
et je ne citerai pas le nom et
qui malgré du début à la fin pour me
dire de faire un dossier des crimes ne
lettre au procureur de faire tout
processus administratif pour garder des
traces
et comment dias est la seule qui m'a
soutenu
voilà on a même contacté le gpu à
l'époque qui était donc de prévention
eux mêmes et qui a fait ce qu'il a vu
c'était fans ou réguliers
on entend qu'elle a été quasiment seul
pour se battre contre des trafiquants de
drogue pardon comment est ce possible en
fait
c'est pas possible c'est une situation à
jouer saluer quand même l'attitude de
madame parce que étant de sénateur des
bouches du rhône connaît cette
problématique là et c'est véritablement
un fléau et le rôle de l'autorité
parentale madama n'a jamais renoncé à
sortir son fils et elle était seule
comme vous dites mais cette attitude
courageuse et et voire même téméraire je
connais
les pressions qu'elle a dû subir pendant
plus de trois ans je pense que l a
l'humilité de ne pas décrire ce qu'elle
a subi mais en même temps ce fléau c'est
d'économie souterraine c'est l'économie
parallèle quand un enfant de 13 ans
voire même parfois même des jeunes de 11
ans maintenant viennent à toucher de
l'argent
journalièrement
avec des montants qui par rapport à une
activité professionnelle classique
peuvent atteindre en fonction la
hiérarchie des sommes astronomiques
la question se pose c'est comment
persuader ces personnes de revenir sur
le droit chemin parce qu'elle me l'ont
tellement l'argent facile que c'est
extrêmement difficile
l'état n'a pas eu la réponse essentielle
premiers éléments la pédagogie vis-à-vis
des élèves dans l'est dans les milieux
scolaires dire qu'il n'y a pas de drogue
récréative quand j'entends ce terme à
récréatif samuel serre je ne comprends
pas on ne s'amuse pas avec la drogue
c'est pas vrai il faut savoir que 100 %
des consommateurs des héros sont passés
par le cannabis il n'y a pas de notion
de drôles de douche pour moi et on va en
parler c'est dur govou souhaité réagir
les enfants qui grandissent dans des
quartiers comme ça ils gagnent en guise
et déjà dans un contexte d'arenthon
d'un environnement hostile d'un
environnement de stigmatisation et de
discrimination
dans ce qui dépasse déjà facile parce
que des gens mais stigmatisées par tous
les médias dès qu'il ya un règlement de
compte on ne parle que de ça
donc on ne voit pas
tous les gens qui sont bien on parle que
les 2% de la population qui font des
trafics de drogue qui sont dans les
trafics de drogue on ne parle pas des 98
% qui travaillent qui passent le bac qui
font des études et cela on n'en parle
pas qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
céline burgos qu'est-ce que quel est le
message de ce que vous dites là aux
sénateurs qui vous écoute je veux qu'ils
vous rêviez déjà qu'ils ouvrent les yeux
parce que je pense que excusez moi
l'expression qu'il était dans sa bulle
début et qu'il ne se rend pas compte
nous nous sommes des agents de terrain
nous savons ce qui se passe nous savons
comment plus ou moins améliorer la
situation
et c'est vrai que j'entends de découpe
qu'est ce qu'il a à dire et des
propositions qu'il a à faire là-dessus
alors peut-être at-il des propositions
stéphane hurel et je vous laisse la
parole ensuite bien sûr oui madame je je
je ne peux pas admettre de cette
position de dire effectivement c'est que
2% c'est pas très grave quand vous avez
des règlements de comptes on stigmatise
pas les médias ne stigmatise pas les
règlements de comptes mais quand vous
avez un enfant de 11 ans pour ça que
j'ai pris le cet exemple là et vous
savez pourquoi je les prix qui tombe
sous les balles c'est que c'est l'échec
de la société c'est notre échec si vous
le voulez mais c'est l'échec de la
société dans sa globalité
là la différence c'est que ya un
phénomène d'impunité hier on était sur
un plateau sur la justice il faut que
l'enfant comprenne dès le premier acte
dès qu'il sort du cadre légal il faut
que la société est une réponse qu elle
soit proportionnée par rapport à ce
qu'il a fait mais il faut que la société
est une réponse aujourd'hui nous sommes
totalement impuissant par rapport à ça
donc c'est vérité par rapport à ces
comportements déviants et aussi beaucoup
de pédagogie on ne fait pas assez de
pédagogie dans l'est dans les écoles la
drogue est un fléau ce n'était pas
quelque chose qui ressemble à l'alcool
puisque on fait souvent des comparaisons
entre la drogue et l'alcool et là aussi
à deux axes la prévention mais également
la répression il faut être beaucoup plus
ferme il faut que les forces de l'ordre
et les moyens également d'intervenir
vous l'avez dit madame vous avez été
seul à un moment au nez quand vous êtes
allé voir les forces de l'ordre donc
effectivement il faut des des renforts
mais également que ces forces là se
spécialise pour ce lutter contre ce
trafic emmanuel macron il ya quelques
semaines notamment sur la sécurité paco
mais aussi la sécurité bernard jomier
banon mais moi ce que je trouve vraiment
intéressant c'est que toutes les deux
vous nous avez expliqué vous nous
expliquer une situation vous vivez
quelqu'un qui est dur je mets en fait
elles sont quand même très différentes
options on peut pas on peut pas dire il
ya un problème deux drogues javert les
usagers de crack c'est très spécifique
c'est une population d'ailleurs vous
pouvez mettre en place tous les
dispositifs que vous voulez il faut un
niveau d'individualisation et il faut
les prendre un par un ça prend beaucoup
de temps c'est moi j'ai travaillé dans
l'ensemble de substitution on donne de
la méthadone aux gens c'est très long
c'est des parcours qui sont très longs
il faut le faire et c'est faisable parce
que le crack c'est très limité dans
notre pays c'est le nord-est parisien et
ses stalingrad cas il ya vingt ans ça
revient etc et puis le problème dont
madame parle à marseille et ses fans le
rudulier qui est beaucoup plus vaste
soulouque et la question en gros du
cannabis beaucoup une économie qui
génère des profits incroyables et des
quartiers entiers qu'on a délaissé et
qui sont happés par ça et c'est pas
parce que c'est facile c'est parce que
aussi c'est là en bas en bas de chez soi
juste un point à stalingrad ya 20 ans on
a fait un panel citoyen parce que déjà
ça allait pas bien à l'époque et donc
les gens sont réunis ils ont travaillé
pendant des mois ils ont dix youn et et
moi j'attendais de savoir ce qu'ils
allaient dire est ce qu'ils voulaient
plus de répression et ce qu'ils
voulaient plus d'éducation vous imaginez
les débats eh ben la conclusion on
l'attendait pas ils ont titré leur
rapport ceux qui l'ont choisi pour un
quartier traiter à égalité avec les
autres et ça revient à la question vous
posiez sûr ça se passerait pas dans le
16e arrondissement
c'est à dire qu'ils nous disaient au
fond on nous respecte pas si la
situation elle dure c'est parce que
notre quartier il n'est pas traité à
égalité avec les autres quartiers est-ce
qu'à marseille on porte la même
attention
quartiers nord qu'à la corniche est ce
qu'on porte la même attention aux
différentes populations est ce qu on
fait attention à ce qu'ils aient le même
accès aux services publics à ce que les
enfants les jeunes aient le même accès
aux différents dispositifs
je pose la question si on entre par le
petit bout de la lorgnette on n'en
sortira pas et tout le monde de réagir
alors jouanno balavoine je crois que
voulait la g et ensuite je vous donne la
parole sonia de la provôté
oui bonjour à tous déjà il ya plein de
choses sur lesquelles gérard au mondial
mais j'essaie de faire sainte déjà
l'alcool c'est aussi là que la drogue
attention à ne pas minimiser ça parce
que des gens qui sont très atteints par
sa deuxième chose moi ce que je remarque
et sont en train d'entendre et qui
révoltant c'est qu'en fait on se rend
compte que les poignées un manque de
moyens qu'il terre que ce soit dans les
autres que ce soit dans les écoles que
ce soit au niveau des forces de l'ordre
qui sont eux aussi abandonnés
on a un vrai problème et c'est là que je
suis d'accord il ya un vrai problème
sociétal assez voilà jean guide quand
même à vous dire que le crack ce n'est
pas que apparaît il ya des gens en bas
ici ils sont jeunes et prennent beaucoup
de crack c'est partout c'est partout et
je pense que si vraiment on veut dans
les prochaines années commencé à se
sortir de tout ça il va falloir qu'on
s'occupe de nos gamins il va vraiment
falloir qu'on s'occupe des enfants qu'on
s'occupe de leur éducation qu'on les
protège parce que c'est des enfants qui
vont devenir adulte et tous les adultes
qui sont aujourd'hui touchées ce sont
des enfants qui ont été blessés ce sont
des enfants dont leurs reines ont étés
pourris donc c'est il va falloir se
secouer il va falloir donner les moyens
aux hôpitaux donner les moyens aux
professeurs j'enfonce des portes
ouvertes mais ça fait quand même des
années qu'il ya d'écrit
au niveau de toutes ces institutions qui
sont abandonnés et pour finir avec les
parents qui sont abandonnés mois céline
je vous trouve pas d'ailleurs ça doit
aussi chaud le trou
exemplaire est admis bhl parce que j'ai
pris moi j'ai consommé pendant 15 ans et
j'en ai vu de tous les bords et tout il
ya une détresse qui
qui est terrible et si on réagit pas
maintenant et je préfèrerais me tromper
mais les cinq dix prochaines années ça
va être une hécatombe et c'est à tous
les niveaux y trouva un avertissement
très fort que vous lancez sonia de la
provôté comment vous recevez cet
avertissement vous élus élus de la haute
assemblée qui avait quand même un peu
plus de pouvoir que nous simples
citoyens d'abord avant d'être élus de la
haute assemblée même si c'est une
débauche de mes fonctions je suis aussi
médecin j'ai un parcours d'élu local ou
pas complètement déconnecté de ces
sujets là élu local là où je travaillais
encore il ya quelques années il ya peu
même et donc
dire que
l'urgence elle est là mais il ya déjà
quinze ans un premier plan triennal tu
prévention des toxicomanies avait tenté
d'être d'être mis en place en france et
que quinze ans après on se retrouve dans
l'acide dans une situation qui ne s'est
pas améliorée qui s'est aggravée parce
que d'abord il ya plus de drogues
différentes parce que les marchés se
pensent que les circuits et les réseaux
se sont étoffés qu'il ya eu une forme de
pas de déni mais en tout cas
une vision un peu souple de la dimension
quand même illégales dangereuses de
cette affaire quoi est
clairement
c'est les choses n'ont pas été prises
complètement à bras le corps alors ben
moi moi je réagis parce que à l'époque
déjà
il y avait trois sujets c'était la
prévention et l'éducation
voilà un sujet un cat ont fait depuis où
en est la prévention dans les écoles
comme entre compagne sont les
adolescents sur sur ces questions là le
deuxième sujet c'était le traitement la
prise en charge comme on accompagne vers
le chiffrage on devait déjà mettre en
place partout d'aider des services
adaptés dans tous les territoires pour
qu'ils aient au moins un endroit
identifiés par chacun à partir du moment
où commençait à rentrer dans un process
identification qu'on avait un problème
une volonté de s'en sortir et et les
bouées de secours et sont elles sont pas
là pas partout en tout cas
les parents les familles des proches qui
sont inquiets des situations
individuelles qui ont envie d'être
conseillés sont pas non plus conseillé
il n'ya pas des maisons des adolescents
partout par exemple tous ces sujets là
voilà et le traitement c'était vraiment
des services haddock parce que
effectivement c'est long et lent le
parcours vers le sevrage et ses jets
lavoine est passée par là mais terminé
parce que le troisième sujet c'est la
répression sir frau ne peut pas à
traiter de cet ensemble si on n'a pas
les trois le trépied qui fonctionne bien
et sur la prise en charge en matière de
répression ou du moins de 2 de 2,2 de
punitif à chaque fois que des réseaux
sont identifiés à chaque fois que des
dealers soient identifiés à chaque fois
qu'on est dans des situations illégales
et dangereuses eh ben ça ça n'a pas
toujours été suivies d'effet c'est à
dire que derrière la justice c'est pas
toujours déclarées a pas toujours assumé
les choses si on n'a pas le trépied
c'est compliqué d'avoir une politique
globale et d'accompagner sainement
j'allais dire sereinement parce que tout
est là et qu'on a tous des outils et je
dois tourner a pas tous les idées outil
c'est très compliqué johanna balavoine
pas été facile pour vous de j'ai envie
de dire oui facile de tomber dans la
drogue c'est un engrenage dans lequel
vous êtes tombé facilement la drogue a
été banalisé ça a été banale léger
débuts au début c'était sympa
avec du recul c'est pas sympa mais oui
c'est une facilité déconcertante comme
moi j'avais 16 ans j'ai pris un petit
ascendant l'instauration et j'étais avec
des gens qu'il ya une distance de
plus chez moi on est sans compter dans
un appartement coquet coquette jours
plus tard on sort en boîte donc j'ai là
j'ai 16 ans je peux entendre walf c'est
pas normal je me retrouve avec de
l'ecstasy
il ya une banalisation
qui est terrible moi ce que j'aimerais
dias et dire que là on est en train de
chercher des solutions à plein de choses
pendant qu'on veut traiter le mal ce qui
je crois et c'est facile à dire il faut
traiter le symptôme pourquoi on consomme
pourquoi il ya encore de la vente dans
la rue pourquoi moi qui arrêté de me
droguer depuis trois ans je ressens
encore des messages des dealers ça fait
trois ans je reçois des messages sable
ouais l'un d'eux attend à ccc la fête
tient qu'au niveau
moi je sais qu'au pays basque ici il y
avait un cartel dans une école où les
gamins ils ont 13 ans c'est partout donc
moi je veux bien qu'on fasse de la
répression c'est toujours important de
femmes de la répression mais la graine
c'est quoi la glâne c'est le trafic
comment ça c'est qu'on a attendu que
marseille soit à feu et à sang pour le
président parle est
anormal c'est pas normal en fait et est
allé expliquer à des gamins
ou même à
tout le monde qu'il faut pas consommer
et valeur 40 dénis qui est globale à ce
niveau là c'est moi c'est si je veux
demain sur consommer les avec une
facilité incroyable et je précise l
album tout à l'heure parce que parce
qu'il ya le cannabis c'est vrai le
cannabis est vu comme quelque chose de
sympa je suis d'accord
d'ailleurs pour dire qu'il n'ya pas de
drogues douces ciel ma drogue mais
l'alcool est une drogue aussi
illégalement j'utilise 15 ans il
rencontre dans un supermarché peuvent
acheter de l'alcool et ça détruit tout
autant et c'est voir pire parce qu'il ya
pas moins cher que de l'alcool c'est à
dire que nos gamins ils y sont diffusées
aujourd'hui sont abandonnés si on
encadre bien les enfants 6 600 fois il
arrive à rêver si ces enfants ils sont
bien éduqués à 6 et enfin ils ont accès
à des activités et qui sortent des
écrans qui sort de tout ça les bardes
déjà la prévention elle est faite elle
est faite pour voir ce cd enfants qu'on
va regarder qui vont être aimé et non
qu'ils vont être abandonnées et pau mais
faisait ça moi j'ai été une gamine qui a
été peu mais tout simplement et
justement battant comme tout le monde et
on va poursuivre cet échange merci
infiniment à toutes les trois de vous
être livré comme vous l'avez fait dans
cette première partie de l'émission on
va poursuivre la discussion avec trois
autres témoignages on va justement
essayer d'explorer les pistes les
solutions on va notamment voir ce qui
est fait en matière de prévention avec
kamel il a lui-même consommé de la
drogue pendant des heures et il en est
sorti aujourd'hui et parle aux jeunes
regardez moi je suis pas là pour faire
un cours solide re pas du tout je
voulais vous ou pas enfin je veux
partager mon expérience avec moi je suis
un ancien toxicomane j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de problèmes dans ma vie avec
les drogues et je suis pas partie de
ceux qui se sont sentis
donc et c'est pour ça je suis envahi
aujourd'hui parce que ça va apporter
tout le monde commençait messi n'est
vraiment pas la portée de tout le monde
s'est arrêté ça c'est classe est à la
portée de tout le monde donc la
dépendance c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit venir la dépendance et ça tombe
dessus mais ceux qui vont réagir il ya
même son chien et kamel guennoun on vous
retrouve en direct avec nous depuis un
établissement scolaire où vous
intervenez justement merci de faire une
pause pour cette émission vous avez 47
ans vous habitez dans le finistère vous
avez trois enfants vous avez fondé il ya
vingt ans l'association de prévention et
d'information sur les conduites
addictives et votre combat on vient de
le voir et vous allez en parler avec
nous c'est de faire de la prévention
auprès des jeunes agathe laurent est
également avec nous bien venu vous avez
28 ans vous habitez entre les
hauts-de-seine et malaga en espagne vous
êtes entrepreneur vous avez un enfant de
18 mois vous êtes une consommatrice
assumé de cannabis vous militez pour la
dépénalisation et même la légalisation
pour vous c'est la voie à suivre pour
mieux accompagner les consommateurs
mieux encadrer la consommation et vous
nous direz pourquoi dans un instant
nicolas ducourneau bienvenue vous avez
40 ans vous êtes coordinateur de la
salle de consommation à strasbourg si je
résume en quelques mots votre pensée
mais vous re préciser les choses bien
sûr pour vous la salle de consommation
cet indispensable c'est une des
solutions mais pas la seule et on verra
ça en détail avec vous kamel guennoun
pour vous la clé c'est d'aller parler
aux jeunes des ravages de la drogue est
ce que votre discours porte est-ce que
ce discours les touchent aussi parce que
vous êtes légitime pour en parler
puisque vous avez connu cela oui enfin
voici ce que me dit souvent les jeunes
cerfs qu'effectivement bah écoute kamel
qui est passée par là donc tu sais un
petit peu de quoi tu parles quand tu
parles doit être dépendance tu sais de
quoi tu parles voilà que tu parles de
priver de liberté tu sais de quoi tu
parles aussi enfin voilà et c'est vrai
que
moi c'est ce que je veux faire passer
comme message en fait moi je ne dis pas
que si j'avais été informé
je me serais pas drogué je dis pas ça je
dis juste que si j'avais été informé
j'aurais loupé l'opportunité d'avoir un
choix
pardon est ce que vous sentez qu'ils
sont réceptifs et à quels types
d'arguments sont ils réceptifs aux
arguments sur la santé sur la sécurité
sur l' isolement que ça peut créer son
isolement sur la santé au fouet ç'a
beaucoup et notamment sur la mémoire moi
je vois ça par rapport au cannabis 1
c'est vrai que les jeunes que je veux
voilà le lilia est largement fait entre
échec scolaire et cannabis moi
j'interviens dans beaucoup
d'établissements scolaires et et c'est
vrai qu'il ya quand même pas mal de
soucis et le problème est national moi
j'interviens au niveau national et
effectivement c'est partout de jaya
tenue et la jaille à castres que j'aille
à bergerac voilà périlleux je rencontre
les mêmes problèmes en fait car je ne
vous le redis tout vouloir raconter
votre histoire en détail les problèmes
de santé
moi je pars de leurs questions en fait
voilà j'ai surtout sache pas vraiment de
leurs questions donc c est comme moi
seront faits pour arrêter de se droguer
paris/londres être des questions qui
sont pertinentes
ccc quoi c'est quoi ils dépendants parce
que c'est là qu'ils entendent plein de
choses et je pense qu'à un moment faut
rectifier un petit peu le tir notamment
autour du cannabis je pense que ouais
voilà il ya beaucoup de gens qui
banalise le cannabis et je trouve ça un
peu dommage pour moi le cannabis il pose
pas de problème aux gens qu'on 25 ou 30
ans c'est pas ça le problème le problème
c'est pour les mineurs c'est pour les
tout jeunes qui sont encore en train de
se construire et pour eux ça peut être
très compliqué j'aurais aimé savoir que
le cannabis est une drogue et anti
motivationnelle ça t'enlève toute
motivation et serait qu'une fois qu'on
est dans le piège on est dedans quoi et
ça peut être très compliqué et où j'en
reparle aussi beaucoup c'est sur le
dealer parce que les dealers selon s'est
pas dit leurs désirs américaine à la
consommation générale d'initiation à se
fait par quelqu'un que je ne connais
parfaitement et ça c'est important de le
dire aussi c'est quoi leur rapport aux à
la drogue et au trafic de drogue est ce
que les réseaux sociaux ont changé
quelque chose par exemple est ce que
pour eux c'est plus facile de s'en
procurer aujourd'hui aubin aujourd'hui
tu vas sur woods ap voilà d'autres
réseaux sociaux tu commences ton produit
été livrés à la maison et ça touche tous
les milieux sociaux
si les garçons away away bohli dit déjà
moyens encore quelques années je dirais
qu'il y avait 60 % d'hommes pour 40% une
femme maintenant les filles ont très
largement rattrapé les garçons moi c'est
du 50 50 franchement et et pour vous en
termes de prévention vous auriez besoin
de plus de moyens d'être accompagnés de
développer cette prévention vous faites
déjà ah oui motivation la moitié de mon
temps je me dirais franchement je n'ai
pas un établissement scolaire et l'autre
moitié de mon temps je le passe à former
des adultes parce qu'ils sont c'est
hyper important donc moi je les découvre
enfin j'aime bien dessiner des
informations des écoles de gendarmerie
je fais les informations auprès de la
police et celle des informations auprès
des infirmières auprès des éducateurs
spécialisés parce que si si les
personnes qui ne pas leur métier seront
en proximité avec ça et ils seront
importants que déjà qu'on est plus à peu
près le même discours qu'on sache à peu
près où est ce qu'on va notamment sur
l'alcool sur d'autres produits parce que
moi je dis je n'arrive pas à comprendre
qu'on puisse séparer l'alcool des
drogues ou à l'alcool est une drogue moi
quand je parle des drogues chi voilà je
cite l'alcool voilà c'est important ça
c'est qui qui revient beaucoup et on l'a
vu déjà en première partie de cette de
cette émission stéphane le rudulier il
faudrait plein de gens comme kamel
guennoun qui aillent dans les
établissements faut la pousser cette
prévention oui on évoquait tout à
l'heure mais quand je vois le rôle
essentiel qu'à ce monsieur au sein des
établissements scolaires des plus jeunes
âges et les jeunes consomment de plus en
plus tôt contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
croire à un moment donné où j'étais près
préservé parce que il était au collège
ou au lycée c'est totalement faux c'est
n'est plus vrai tout au contraire et
donc le rôle de de ce monsieur de dire
attention s'épandent il n'y a pas de
drogues douces ya pas de drogue récré
récréatif à usage récréatif plus tôt
mais il ya surtout des droits qui amène
à la psychose aux troubles du
comportement au fait qu' on soit en
échec scolaire en désocialisation
également et bien ça c'est un message
qu'il faut porter aux jeunes en dix ans
mais pas là dedans et pour ce parce que
j'entends qu'il ya deux volets pour ceux
qui ont déjà essayé qui sont amenés à
tomber là dedans et bien effectivement
vous avez un rôle essentiel également
pour dire voilà comment on peut s'en
sortir avec quels acteurs on peut s'en
sortir et donc c'est ce volet prévention
on appareils de la répression mais volet
prévention est essentielle et il faut le
développer et ça lui puisque si
j'entends bien et aussi la formation qui
est faite auprès de nos partenaires
institutionnels que ça soit aussi bien
des forces de l'ordre des infirmières ou
autre il faudrait multiplier ce genre
d'initiative aller à l'échelon du
territoire national afin qu'on puisse
véritablement mène une politique
nationale de kamel déroule à venir dans
les bouches du rhône ab non mais écoutez
non mais je voudrais cela au sénat mais
j'en ai de la réunion ou en audition
mais dans les bouches-du-rhône où on
aurait besoin de 2 km 1 km x 1000 ou
2000 pour véritablement avoir une
politique de prévention efficace quand
on parle de prévention c'est vrai qu'on
a on se demande pourquoi il ya si peu
aussi rarement des campagnes de
prévention nationale sonia de la provôté
c'est vrai que la prévention ça peut
aussi passer par des messages nationaux
ça peut être de grande ampleur pourquoi
ce sont des des personnes des individus
qui seul agissent au quotidien comme
camel en allant dans les établissements
ça peut être du plus grande parce que il
ya il ya plusieurs dimensions dans tout
ça le message national c'est le message
collectif et le message collectif
lommois grand plaisir depuis une
vingtaine d'années c'est qu'il est plus
que confus et que le cannabis d'il ya 20
ans et pas celui de maintenant et qui a
tout un tas de sujets quand même pour
lesquels il faut quand même remettre un
petit peu les compteurs à zéro et avoir
quelque chose de clair
même le message politique en l'espace
d'un mandat est pas tout à fait le même
donc on voit bien que tout ça est très
évolutif et que y'en a des lobbys pour
des lobbys contre moi je pense que c'est
complémentaire il faudrait qu'on se met
au clair sur message national et que la
parole politique médiatique ou de
porteurs identifiés que sont des
personnes connues et c'est que c'est par
là soit à peu près unitaire est enfin là
on peut qu'on vient de traverser avec la
crise montrent bien qu'on a du mal à
avoir des paroles unique sur des sujets
graves et le deuxième sujet c'est
l'accompagnement plutôt collectif à plus
petite échelle sur des populations
ciblées les jeunes par exemple
typiquement les jeunes et les parents
là je réagis sur sur les jeunes chacun
il prend ce qui vaut dans les jeunes y
en a qui ont peur de la répression il y
en a qui ont peur de la maladie il y en
a qui disent ah ça m'a tenté mais c'est
mon copain tiens qui m'a présenté ça
donc ça effectivement j'aurais bien fait
j'ai bien fait de me méfier enfin je
veux dire l'information et lé par de
multiples canaux mais la prévention des
campagnes nationales honnêtement d'état
tuer les changes je ne sais même pas ce
qu'on serait capable de proposer comme
caisse nationale unis lui la force de
kamel c'est son expérience bien c est sa
légitimité sa légitimité par rapport à
son expérience elle contacts directs
c'est-à-dire le local si on peut faire
des spots publicitaires sur les grands
chaînes d'information à 20 heures je
pense pas que ça touchera
essentiellement principalement les
jeunes par contre aller dans l'enceinte
scolaire pour rapporter son expérience
en exemple moi je m'en suis sorti mais
attention il ya un véritable danger
c'est beaucoup plus marquants je pense
pour un jeu car ce qu'un spot
publicitaire n'a jamais il est un peu
floue le message des autorités bah oui
en vous entendant quand même jeu je
pense que les actions locales sont très
importantes les et pince mais n'exonère
pas d'une clarté du cadre national sinon
le sinon les gens comprennent pas et
encore une fois on en revient à la
question des produits à la question de
l'interdît dans notre société kamel il a
parlé du cannabis il a parlé de l'alcool
et un usage modéré de l'alcool qui pose
pas de problème et un usage de l'alcool
qui pose un grand problème le cannabis
c'est délétères pour la santé faux pas
en consommer mais il faut bien
reconnaître en même temps qu' un usage
du cannabis
ce qui pose pas vraiment de problème
sauf économique mais je vais revenir et
puis à tout un duel du cannabis qui est
dramatique bon et le problème c'est que
quand vous avez dans des caisses qui
peuvent comprendre les jeunes quand il
ya une substance qui circulent
massivement qui a été consommé qui est
consommé par la case ih la majorité
d'entre eux je crois dans les dernières
données et que l'état dit c'est interdit
c'est interdit et que c'est pas
appliquée ça ne peut pas fonctionner
alors il ya deux branches cohérente il y
en a une qui est de renforcer la guerre
au cannabis voilà et d'aller dans la
guerre plus forte je pense que on va
s'épuiser et et notre branche les noces
blanches qui est de dire qu' il faut
reprendre en main toute l'économie qui a
derrière et là c'est une question qui
est extrêmement difficile
c'est à dire toute l'économie qui s'est
créée qui satisfait des tas de gens qui
études pour des tas de gens y compris
qu'ils sont des gens très éduquée des
gens qui on aime des moyens qui sont
voilà qui est bon bref et donc c'est
pour ça que moi je pense je mets les
pieds dans le plat je suis désolé de le
faire brièvement mais c'est l'exercice
d'aujourd'hui alors la question n'est
pas simple mais je pense que là où on en
est sûr cette substance là il ya des tas
de substance il faut maintenir un
interne une prohibition totale et plus
ferme et plus fortes mais que sur le
cannabis il faut que l'état prenne cette
substance et organise on va dire
malheureusement sa vente il ya deux
méthodes et j'en termine à t'apprendre
20 secondes dans le monde il ya deux il
ya eu deux façons de faire ce que ceux
qui sont lancé là dedans et à la
légalisation j'ai à dire économique en
grossistes ont créé le marché il ya des
consommateurs et c'est une catastrophe
la légalisation économique ça fait
flamber la consommation et y aller avec
l'égalisation comme certains états
américains
sanitaire qui est encadré qui accompagne
et d'investissement dans les programmes
de prévention dans les programmes
d'accompagnement et qui fait baisser la
consommation et suisses ont regardé ça
de près c'est ça qu'il faut regarder ce
qu'il vous dit ferri gires beaucoup
agathe laurent que je vois et vous allez
découvrir en visio avec vous parce que
vous parliez d'un usage du cannabis qui
ne pose pas de problème il est incarné
par agathe laurent des comptes dans
cette émission bonjour vous fumer des
joints des joints tous les soirs pour
vous détendre comment du coup vous
entendez ce qu'on est en train de dire
sur ce plateau et le combat de kamel lui
est en train d'expliquer aux jeunes
surtout n'y touchez pas et vous vous
dites il faut légaliser
oui alors en fait il ya quand même un
détail on n'est pas égaux face à la
drogue et d'ailleurs kamei commencé dans
la vidéo qu'on a vu ça donc j'appelle ma
femme tombe dedans et tape la maison ça
leur fait pas grand chose on a tous fait
un ami qui achètent des cigarettes et
qui a arrêté du jour un enfant problèmes
auxquels du canal x beaucoup d'usagers
contrôle a réussit à contrôler leur
consommation
moi je ne dirais pas que ça ne m'a pas
posé de problème j'ai déjà eu des
périodes de consommation que je juge
excessives tellement j'ai eu une
capacité à retrouver une consommation
responsable
il faut savoir que le cannabis il ya une
certaine auto médication qui est
pratiqué avec par exemple pour les
menstruations ça fonctionne très bien et
que le sujet en fait du cannabis médical
et du canal du ce qu'on appelle
récréatif est un sujet compliqué parce
que c'est pas si chaque état de fait par
et les deux missions sont légalisés de
cette comment savoir qui aura un usage
responsable vous dites on n'est pas
égaux face à ça mais comment savoir qui
saura gérer et qui ne sera pas gérée et
bien je pense déjà que la légalisation
prêt plutôt une coop on appellerait
plutôt une régulation et qu'on partirait
vers le modèle à qui a été présentée
juste avant avec une avec une sorte de
vision
associative et pas commercial donc par
exemple la création de dé cannabis club
du système d kanabeach clubs qui
seraient les associations on pourrait se
fournir en ayant toutes les informations
on pourrait être encadré on pourrait par
exemple où il pourrait se tenir des
conférences avec kamel
et où en fait on aurait un nombre limité
de membres qui discuteraient qui
pourraient échanger sur leur
consommation de quelque sorte en fait
qu'on réduirait qu'on appelle les riffs
que les risques psychosociaux
c'est à dire que les personnes
pourraient se protéger les deux les
autres frais d offre une consommation
devient problématique
il était musulman par exemple kamel
ghiles houle du cannabis club c'est
quelque chose qui vous fait réagir ouais
ouais au complet puisque quand j'entends
de dire qu'il faut être raisonnable oui
effectivement à 25 ans ont peu aidé
raisonnable à 28 ans on peut peut-être
est raisonnable mais à 14 15 ans chaque
son est vraiment raisonnable et il est
bien là le problème donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment faire le distinguo entre
les et voilà des adultes et des mineurs
pour moi c'est pas du tout pareil et je
pense qu'en légalisant le produit s'est
passé qui va changer l'axé soir en face
on sait déjà il va par exemple de
l'alcool s'il est légal normalement il
ya une loi qui dit qu'on peut pas
acheter d'alcool le produit leader ne
peut pas celle opposant les deux autres
fins dans l'être les voilà dans les
magasins puis ça alors que je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de faire des lois ou
de faire appliquer ces qui sont en
vigueur puisque n'importe quel gamin à
peu aller acheter de l'alcool dans un
magasin d'apprendre qu'il est gamin on
peut acheter dans du tabac dans un
bureau de tabac donc après comprend
qu'il fasse qu'il faille passer faire
passer l'information mais de la voile à
diviser vos mots sur ce qui s'est passé
ça banalise
alors moi j'ai une toute autre approche
parce que si vous voulez dès lors qu' on
va essayer de légaliser quel que soit
j'entends bien les deux dimensions
première réaction c'est je me dis bon on
n'arrive pas à endiguer le fléau de la
drogue
demain on arrive pas on dit la
prostitution valait légaliser on
n'arrive pas à endiguer le trafic
d'armes on va le légaliser et ça va
forcément l'égalisation et ghadbane et
banalisation premiers éléments le
deuxième allemand et l'a7 sur un aspect
peut-être un peu plus profond les
trafiquants qui génère des millions
d'euros par mois par rapport au cannabis
vont peut-être avoir la tentation de se
tourner vers d'autres substances est
peut-être encore plus dangereuse et plus
nocives des vergers
pardon à l'isic continuité car elle dit
c'est déjà fait c'est déjà fait mais
justement veulent ça va se faire que se
renforcer et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je préférais avant un cadre
strict et qu'on renforce véritablement
la prévention vis-à-vis des jeunes parce
que pour moi c'est essentiel c'est un
combat impunité vraiment avec des peines
sévères on n'a pas trop parlé des
consommateurs ça a été dit mais il n'ya
pas que des consommateurs qui vivent
dans la précarité ou qui sont en
déshérence il ya certains disent on le
classe sociale même classe sociale
supérieure à travers seul usage
récréatif du cannabis qui passe de très
bonne soirée et qui contribuent à ces
trafics également et à la valorisation
de ces trafics et c'est là où il faut
que l'état est une réponse très ferme
vis-à-vis également des consommateurs et
de la peine qui est de 100 euros pour
l'heure et qui n'est pas appliquée et là
je vous rejoins et un problème
d'application du cadre législatif
puisque très peu de consommateurs sont
quand même pénalisé sonia de la provôté
ensuite je vais me tourner vers nicolas
ducourneau oui pour dire que l'on peut
pas on peut absolument pas banaliser
moi j'entends bien que à votre âge on
puisse tout à fait
fumer un joint j'entends votre
témoignage en tout cas on entend aussi
énormément d'autres témoignages d'une
tout autre nature sur sur des phénomènes
de dépendance ne viennent pas témoigner
ceux qui ont
finalement eu des bouffées délirantes et
des moments dramatiques ne viennent pas
ce tous témoigner ceux qui ont eu des
idées suicidaires qui ont eu des des
traverses et terry dont ils ne sont pas
de sortie je veux dire quand on quand on
est médecin c'est aussi d'aider des
fâcheux d'un se sont pas des situations
rares ce ne sont pas des situations rare
on considère que chez les consommateurs
aiguilles en à 20% qui déclenche une
addiction tels qu'ils ont des troubles
graves qui en découlent et qu' il faut
pas sous dimensionné cette problématique
de santé publique est une problématique
réelle et est considéré qu'on a le libre
arbitre
c'est pas tout à fait vrai à partir du
moment où il ya dépendance et addition
on n'a pas le libre arbitre on n'a pas
le libre arbitre donc il faut toujours à
un moment qui est un élément déclencheur
une épaule quelqu'un une information qui
permet de se dire qu'on est à nouveau en
situation de choix mais c'est pas tout à
fait spontané cette situation de choix
quand on est bien entouré et qu'on vous
conseille vers le choix et qu'on arrive
à s'en sortir soit même tant mieux mais
c'est pas c'est pas le cas de figure le
plus fréquent c'est pas tout à fait vrai
et donc on doit vraiment vraiment
accompagner et là je ré insiste
là-dessus j'ai l'impression de revivre
la même chose depuis le début mais si on
n'a pas les structures d'accompagnement
si on n'a pas le message individuel si
on n'a pas la prise en charge haddock
sur mesure eh bien on aura toujours de
grandes difficultés avec tout un tas de
deux jeunes et de personnes ou un jeune
qui n'arriveront pas à s'en sortir parce
qu'on n'aura pas mis les moyens et les
compétences pour ça alors les structures
parlons-en pas pour le cannabis mais
pour des drogues plus dures nicolas
ducourneau vous travaillez dans une
salle de consommation
il ya beaucoup de faux discours et de
fantasmes autour des salles de
consommation qui sont parfois appelées
salles de shoot d'ailleurs ça veut dire
beaucoup expliquez-nous clairement ce
qui s'y passe dans ces structures
comment ça se passe très concrètement
alors effectivement on s'adresse cette
fois douze personnes d'autres publics on
a parlé longuement ici des de cannabis
et des deux jeunes gens là on s'adresse
plutôt à des personnes qui sont en prise
avec les consommations des consommateurs
actifs et là on est plutôt sur le
versant de ce qu'on appelle la réduction
des risques donc l'idée c'est
d'accueillir les personnes c'est d'abord
un lieu d'accueil comme il en existe
d'autres comme il en existe depuis des
années en france notamment les centres
d'accueil et de soins en addictologie
mais cette fois où les personnes ont la
possibilité de consommer à moindre
risque dans un espace sécurisé sous la
supervision de d'intervenants sociaux
sanitaires
voilà l'idée c'est qu'elle quand bien
même elles consomment les bains qu'elle
puisse le faire dans des conditions
sanitaires acceptables
pas à la rue et qu'elles puissent
réduire les risques liés à leur
consommation par risque on entend
risque d'overdose risque de transmission
d'hépatite c du vih risque infectieux
etc
les personnes ont la possibilité d'y
consommer mais du coup d'entrer en
contact avec des équipes d'intervenants
elles ont la possibilité aussi de faire
dépister puisqu'on parle de réduction
des risques notamment de risque vih
elles ont aussi la possibilité de faire
dépister pour qu'elles connaissent leur
statut sérologique
voilà encore une fois donc là on
s'adresse à des usagers actifs
essentiellement par voie intraveineuse
donc pour des personnes qui s'injectent
et voilà et donc on est sur des missions
de réduction des risques et d'accès aux
droits et d'accès aux soins dont on
accompagne les personnes dans leur
global donc réduction des risques mais
si je vous comprends bien pas
spécialement réduction de consommation
ce ne sont pas des gens qui décroche
après un passage par votre structure
ça peut disons que c'est pas la
condition d'accueil a priori c'est pas
un préalable
on ne demande pas aux personnes qu'elle
soit dans une logique d'abstinence à
priori pour les accueillir les
accompagner mais ça peut en fonction des
envies des personnes et en fonction de
là où elles sont présents sont dans leur
parcours de vie et de soins c'est des
choses qu'on aborde tous les jours qu'on
parle tous les jours de de sevrage avec
les personnes du coup ça se passe pas au
sein la salle de consommation mais ça se
passe sur d'autres dispositifs dans
d'autres structures avec lesquelles on
travaille et vers lesquelles on oriente
les personnes les salles de consommation
c'est un maillon un supplémentaire qui
vient s'intégrer un réseau à une chaîne
de soins disons déjà existence est lancé
parce que c'est un peu ce qui se profile
à on a des annonces gouvernementales qui
annonce d'autres salles de consommation
c'est quelque chose que vous saluer
oui je peux que le salut et puisque au
quotidien je je vois les bénéfices qu'en
retire les personnes les études le
montrent on a parlé d'un rapport de
l'inserm tout à l'heure l'évaluation de
l'inserm qui a une fois de plus prouvé
les bénéfices des salles de consommation
par rapport aux objectifs de réduction
des risques et d'accès aux soins on a
des expériences à l'étranger depuis plus
de 30 ans qui ont également montré les
avantages et montrer que les des salles
de consommation à moindre risque sont
utiles ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
moins de consommation de rue sur
l'aspect tranquillité publique moins de
consommation de rue - de seringue
abandonné dans l'espace public et sur le
volet santé publique ça veut dire moins
de passages aux urgences
- le comportement risque donc sur une
étude qui a été faite auprès d'usagers
qui fréquentent des salles de
consommation et d'autres qui ne
fréquentent pas des usagers qui vivent
dans des paris à strasbourg où il ya une
salle de consommation et d'autres qui
vivent ailleurs
voilà donc encore une fois ce rapport a
montré l'utilité des sacs de
consommation et c'est pour ça qu'il est
question l'a22
effectivement de favoriser leur
développement sur deux territoires et
dans d'autres et de les multiplier
consensus autour de cette table sur les
salles de consommation bernard jomier
bas beaucoup plus qu'il ya quelques
années parce que comme l'a raconté
nicolas du corneau quand on a ouvert
donc à paris dans le 10ème et piastres
âge lourd immédiatement après c'était
très conflictuelle et il a fallu un
engagement conjoint et ça c'est un point
très important de l'état des
collectivités territoriales de ceux qui
s'occupent de santé de ceux qui
s'occupent de sécurité donc des
autorités sanitaires de la préfecture de
police pour qu'on mette au point
l'ouverture de ces salles et je peux
louis les mentalités ont mûri parce que
ça a été long on a attendu pendant des
années mais là olivier v en présente
dans la loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale qui arrive au parlement dans
quelques semaines un dispositif plus
complet d'ailleurs parce que je pense
que c'est ce que c'est toujours du mal
lorient lors non parce que 1986 la
première salle y en a plus de sens dans
le monde y en a des dizaines en
allemagne passons on n'y fait pas que de
la consommation à moindre risque on y
fait bien autre chose comme ça a été
expliquée de l'année saga et de tirer et
c'est très long on entend des gens pour
les amener progrès progressivement vers
moins de consommation peut être un
programme de substitution
et puis un sevrage bien sûr si c'est
possible si c'est dans trois ans dans
cinq ans dans dix ans l'important c'est
de d'extraire les gens de l'alliance a
cessé de les aider et de les accompagner
et donc le dispositif qui va nous être
soumis moi je le dis je les dis à
olivier verrey hier soir je pense que
c'est un bon dispositif est qu'il faut
qu'ils aient un consensus politique qui
se crée autour et tout le monde n'était
pas convaincu au début je sais pas si
vous l'êtes stéphanie régulier convaincu
qu'il faut des structures
d'accompagnement effectivement je pense
qu'elle ne porte pas bien leur nom à
l'heure actuelle salles de shoot on
aurait tendance à dire on encourage la
consommation c'est pas du tout de tout
le cas maintenant il ya juste un point
sur leurs localités leur localisation et
leur périmètre un périmètre ça a été dit
tout à l'heure je pense qu'il faut avoir
une réflexion et là on a besoin aussi
des élus locaux des collectivités
territoriales pour avoir précisément une
localisation ou adossés à une structure
de santé on a fait la même chose à paris
à strasbourg cercle après des premiers
projets à paris côté dans un immeuble
d'habitation
on les a mis dans des enceintes
hospitalière mais je pense que c'est la
solution je pense si on peut une deux
semaines ça se discute le disque lui
vécu un parcours parce que effectivement
il n'ya pas que la salle mais ce sera en
milieu urbain quand même il faut aussi
en prendre acte
il est super peut-être rapidement
nicolas ducourneau oui effectivement
l'implantation si c'est primordial à la
fois pour l'accès des usagers qui sont
les premiers concernés parce
qu'effectivement ça donne l'idée s'est
trouvé un compromis en équilibre entre
d'offrir la possibilité aux personnes
d'y accéder facilement donc que la salle
ne sera pas trop isolé des scènes de
consommation effectivement faut qu'il ya
un dialogue pour qu'elle puisse
s'implanter sereinement avec les
riverains et les habitants autour si
vous voulez le contexte entre paris et
strasbourg il est très différent dans la
mesure où à strasbourg ya pas comme à
paris de sa nouvelle c'est à dire des
scènes de consommation a massive comme
on les voit actuellement tout autour du
crack donc le voilà le contexte n'est
pas tout à fait le même c'est important
que dès lors qu'il ya une scène ouverte
la salle s'implante dessus dans l'idée
aussi d'assécher cette salle où air
c'est ce qu'ont fait les suisses a été
dit des 86
dans une démarche tout à fait
pragmatique c'est l idée que voilà il ya
des départs que totalement laissée à
l'abandon où il y avait des salles de
consommation et c'est dans ce contexte
là que la première salle a été ouverte à
berne en suisse et ça fonctionnait
intérêt pour les questions de santé
publique nous on a mis l'accent à
strasbourg sur la question de la santé
publique et
voilà dix ont du coup on s'est implanté
au sein de l'hôpital civil il n'y a pas
d'habitations entoure donc quelque part
ça gêne personne alors tant mieux donc
on pourrait le regretter aussi puisque
l'idée quand même c'est que ces salles
puissent s'inscrire dans parce que les
personnes usagères de drogues sont des
citoyens avant tout et que ces salles
puissent s'inscrire finalement dans la
communauté dans la cité ça c'est
important aussi à genève la salle de
john r elle est à côté de la gare quel
c'est un algeco vert fluo personne ne
peut passer à côté
la salle s'appelle quai 9 à la gare de
genève vient piquer et la salle
s'appelle quai 9 comme ça en dit long
sur voilà l'inscription social vaut
cette salle en suisse à genève et il
nous reste très peu de temps et demander
à tous les trois en plateau de peut-être
conclure en quelques secondes par
rapport à tout ce qui a été dit dans
cette émission ça a été très riche et
merci à évidemment à tous pour vos
témoignages ce que ça peut vous inspirer
pour la suite pour votre travail
législatif avoue sonia de la provôté
d'abord réagir sur ce qui vient d'être
dit et dire que moi aussi je mens je
m'inscris donc dans la logique de
fonctionnement de ces structures est
encore une fois à dos et sur un projet
de territoire avec à la fois la
dimension sociale sanitaire est vraiment
que ce soit dans un réseau parce que
effectivement à partir du moment où on
remet les gens finalement dans un
parcours c'est ça le sujet c'est c'est
ça peut être parfois ténue cette attache
mais c'est pas bien par le sang que le
contact et les choses se refont
sur le plan législatif honnêtement ne
pas réinventer ce qui avait déjà été
imaginé il ya quinze ans que je le redis
encore une fois je dire il ya un trépied
il ya la prévention il ya
l'accompagnement et puis il y a
évidemment le volet répressif est en
tout cas avoir une espèce de forme de
rigueur pour que ces trois éléments là
soit mis en place sans pareil
voilà en quelques mots je suis d'accord
à ce que vient de dire sonia de la
provôté ces questions qui sont des
questions complexes entre et sanitaires
sociétal la sécurité les riverains le
bon elle ne se règlent que quand ce en
se mettant autour de la table et à la
fin en tranchant en prenant en prenant
des décisions mais il faut avoir la
capacité quand même d'écouter de ne pas
stigmatiser ne pas montrer du doigt et
d'essayer de prendre une décision qui au
fond nous permettent à ce que chacun
soit entendue et respectée les riverains
ont raison de dire qu'ils veulent vivre
tranquillement et les usagers de drogues
ont besoin d'être accompagnés pour leur
parcours et pour mieux vivre voilà il
faut que les politiques acceptent de
parents d'après les décisions qui seront
nécessaires cet effet mais résigné non
je pense que c'est un vraiment un sujet
un phénomène de société qu'il faut
traiter à bras le corps ce que j'ai pu
remarquer c'est qu'ils avaient quand
même consensus au sein de différents
groupes politiques mais ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'on peut pas se
permettre de se diviser sur un sujet
aussi sensible et ce sera le mot de la
fin merci merci infiniment à tous et à
toutes participer à cette émission à
cette première de la saison de dialogue
citoyen on se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat bientôt
[Musique]